welcome back to game sports coverage of
e3 2019 we are deep in the sake of the
show I'm Mike McCarty here with Michael
hi um but uh I'm also here with Joe
hello and another Mike that's right yeah
sorry sixth day including not gonna get
confusing it alone show can't tell by
the shirt they're from rare working on
sea of thebes a game that at this point
launched how long ago a year and a bit
yeah a little bit yeah last time we hung
out it was right before a launch yeah I
mean the e3 before launch yes right so
2017 yes the games come a long way it
hasn't I mean I was just we were talking
how many months ago was that all of a
sudden it just like blew up the the
twisters December and kind of January
and stuff yeah yeah all of a sudden
people are like seep these is like
beating and we go and everything on
Twitch what's that like and I mean we'll
get more into the nitty-gritty but
what's it like seeing the game kind of
evolve into that he's not sure he spoils
Roy it's ready schools a new update that
we dropped in November that kind of
pulled all the elements that we'd added
to the game so far along with some new
ones and just kind of put the bow on
everything that we've added and I think
just to me that sense of timing it
really kind of blew up right and we saw
a lot of lots of stream is coming and it
Drive a lot of interest in see your
thieves and I guess the great thing
about our game is that some of the
choices we've made around our
progression system and the way there's
no vertical progression in the game that
people can kind of join at any point and
not feel like they're left behind but
take advantage of all the great content
that we've added since launch and like
that's what we continue to do to this
point right yeah but I think as a team
and a studio it's a bit surreal isn't it
it's like when it when it just because
it's this organic thing that happens
right you release an update and it just
so happens that like one big streamer
comes in and then you kind of get this
influx and you know to have like ninja
playing kind of like just coming in and
playing we heard a rumor that you might
be coming at something because like
something like someone reached out to us
for codes because obviously it's very
expensive game isn't it but but but then
you know to have just people kind of
coming in and playing and watching it
for the first time experience it and see
how they play and like it was incredible
and for the whole studio you're just
like imagine you're like on this crest
of away yeah right and and then that
drives like the the actual player base
and just that like grew so between like
before shrouded so I was launched and
then like a month
later on monthly active user base
doubled so literally like like you know
we have this incredible spike and then
we've kind of just ridden that all the
way through to the anniversary update
which we released after the anniversary
because you know that's what you do tell
us about what like you're really pushing
at the show that like what's the newest
things people from like CEO thieves can
be flying yeah I mean like there's the
two biggest components of what we
released anniversary like what little
over a month ago yeah but was tall tales
and arena I mean they're they're they're
kind of the big features that we've
added and but last year like we you know
we've learned so much we tried to like a
bunch of kind of like different ways to
like surface content and one of those
was experimenting with law in the game
like we introduced like little stories
as part of hungry and deep and we built
on that weaker sales and it really
resonated with the players the idea of
not just turning on a feature is like
part of a buncha patch no it's actually
celebrating it in the game as a moment
of time with character then that little
bit of a story and we loved the idea and
the ambition of trying to deliver more
story and more narrative in the series
will but still having it in that shared
world you know you're feeling all the
feelings that you feel when you play
like a traditional story experience like
you're feeling the highs and the lows
and you know you feel you're on this
adventure but you sharing it with your
friends but you're still in a world
where the storm can roll in you can
still come across a Kraken so like it's
it's kind of compliment this idea of
players creating stories together you
can have this adventure on demand and
kind of the counterpoint to that is
arena which is gone to the other big
area which is give me that competitive
experience on demand you can come in you
can have a great sea of these experience
in 24 minutes now have all the toys and
loads of strategizing of getting into
ship combat going after treasure like
very different experiences but
complimentary to like the core kind of
game of seer thieves and then the other
big thing he's like something nobody
asked for which was fishing right I mean
nobody won't know but it was like no one
ever wants fishing in a game where
there's all this war run boats right
yeah what like why would you want that
no I don't know but we added it anyway
and that's that no joking aside like
like so proud of the team's work on
fishing it feels like this really
immersive mechanic you know all the
feedbacks on the rod and on the line
there's all fish around the world
different rarities you can find bait in
the world
flying these kind of rare captures and
progress with a new trading companies on
a new progression options for whether
you're a pirate legend or whether you're
a new player so like really feels like a
paradigm shift for seared peeves and
like we've taken the opportunity to come
to eat these legs I get the word out
there avoid all this new content you can
come an experience and see if these
today you know the games in-game pass
come in try Co these and I we really
hope you can fall in love with it like
so many of our awesome fans yeah and and
at this eve breanne like on Monday we
did our first kind of Invitational
stream where we invited a bunch of
streamers on mixer to come and play the
arena got about the show here they say
we pick captains and they all get it
kind of pick their crews and we had a
crew didn't we where I was the captain
and I got to pick streamers from the
CFA's community and I may have picked
some quite good ones that were really
good at sea of thieves and really get it
every now and who won I remember I think
you wasn't it wouldn't you won at your
own game
I did win at my own game and I'm really
proud of it the hubris trophy I think
but honestly it's it was so intense I
keep and it's the first time we've done
this kind of Invitational kind of
tournament thing and so you know we
launched see if these like said over a
year ago and that for the last year it's
been adventure right which is where you
know just this preformed emergent world
and now and we've grown it and we've
evolved it and it's now this really rich
experience with the tall tales and stuff
like you talked about but it feels like
arenas at the start of that kind of
journey right and so like we we've got
it out there we've been testing it we've
been getting feedback in this but and
what we NAT what what we know is that
when you have really competitive crews
going up against each other
it is super intense and it just works
right and I think the same applies to it
you know it's just like if you're if
you're matched with people of the right
skills which is what a tournament kind
of thing could bring together it's like
nothing else and so but in the live game
at the moment like we know that there's
improvements we can make
how we match people together because
there's no kind of matching you just get
loaded with others and if that some
unbalanced it's not satisfying when you
win and it's frustrating when you lose
so that's like but tournament show that
whether it's planets it's amazing so we
we need to go kind of address that in
the live game and make it as young as
possible yeah but to have one of tested
out this invitational here in it which
and it was really successful everyone at
home what you know was was watching it
and loving it and so as we look to the
future and we looked at different shows
and different things that is gonna be a
big thing that we want to go and push
off to it and got to go after right and
give give streamers and members of our
community a chance to qualify for these
kind of things and really try and grow
this competitive kind of CF deeds mode
and experience alongside adventurer jump
keep going them because we've got the
two platforms and it's now just come on
it grow them in tandem and and you have
to learn the new set of skills is
Iturbide right to kind of take your mind
out of the emergent thing and make it
competitive but still have emergence and
surprise yeah absolutely I mean like
I've something so great a better insider
program like testing arena like things
like cursed cannibals and skeletons you
think they'd work perfectly in arena
because it's all about getting all these
dozens of dynamic elements in there but
what we've quickly realized that you
know that's gonna unbalance that kind of
fair playing field of being out there
and having this high intensity kind of
competitive experience so like that's
what's been great bear insider program
right to test some of these features ya
know it's like our insiders our
community it's so passionate and you
know with like some of the feedback
around arena is we have the different
side ships in there so that's something
we're working on at the moment at the
studio and again we'll put that out and
we'll test it and we'll balance it with
that inside the community so that when
we get it out to everybody else it's
it's already the right balance we've
already learn one of any issues with it
and stuff because probably for the first
six months of the game we were just
releasing stuff straight to our
community and sometimes we got it wrong
or we miscommunicated around a thing or
there were bugs and but we've we've
learned and grown and we're at a much
smoother in terms of how we update the
game and how we communicate and and it
really feels like we've hit our stride
you then you have something like
competitive shift combat in mind when
you first need see if either that's
something that organically grows I don't
like it was it originally it was like
like they're titled internally the sea
of blood they
but that felt a little bit to do a
little bit i grow didn't ya the idea of
like that you know that the way the ship
mechanics worked on c-- Earthies where
it's it's not only about your mastery of
the controller and your skills it's
about how you use those soft skills to
strategize now you communicate and
assign roles dynamically that really
makes a difference between kind of like
average cues and fantastic crews that's
why things like the invitation on those
competitive events where every crew
knows what they're doing they've got
their own code words and they're
strategizing effectively that's always
been fun right means the basis for like
when we bought see these two III before
like it's essentially like what we've
got with arena right like I'm it's great
kind of it condensed 24-minute
experience where every crew kind of like
knows what they're doing and they're
strategizing together so yeah I mean
it's it's a game of like as fun to watch
as it is to play here well that was kind
of it right that we we kind of prototype
the arena by doing III playable before
we launch because how do we do at you
know a fifteen to thirty minute play
session experience for the show floor
because in adventure you're out there
for an hour two hours alright just
spoiling so it was like okay well shrink
the world in will bring your hands
closer together we'll put ships closer
together and then we'll just want to put
them into the world and see what happens
so what we played those first couple
years was kind of what the arena is now
and you know we had to create custom
builds and things whereas for this EP we
just bring the arena because it's like
oh it's twenty four minutes and it's
perfectly safe over here for the show
floor right so yeah it's we've like
we've always had that in mind but it's
it I think we've got so many plans and
so many ideas and it's about when's the
right time to bring them in like for
pretty much everything because the
amount of questions you get about would
you put this in or you like which does
this make sense all ideas basically fit
broadly and yeah that makes sense we see
if thieves will hit that eventually or
it doesn't make sense for our experience
and light and most most things that you
can think of do you make sense right
because it's a pirate game and your
imagination like fishing makes sense
right and ship damage that you've seen
there makes sense and so it's yeah it's
just like how far can we go how big can
we go and and I think in it we've like
recently we just went past eight point
four million players that have played to
thieves so far which were a new IP right
like is incredible right in just over a
year and since anniversary which
launched kind of it
just like the end of April so starting
May we've had over two million players
play the game alone in that time so
liked it and kind of the month of May
was our third highest month in terms of
player numbers since launch so Lawrence
once was the highest then the second was
the second month and so this was the
third highest and we're like 50 months
off yeah it's like you know we are in a
lot of ways as a service we're only just
beginning but we've got a slide back it
like as part of our kind of future
strategy plans and stuff like the thing
looking at all the games that are out
there were services am you've got World
of Warcraft would like the amount of
years that's been out and like then that
you know League of Legends all these
things that have been out there for ages
and then at the bottom you kind of just
got us because we use it just to
demonstrate that yeah we've been out a
year and but we are literally just at
the star of where we can take this and
to be having this success that we've had
recently to be to have the kind of the
platform now to grow and for us honestly
to be much better at how we deliver and
how we grow and and like having learned
everything we've learned over the last
year I think the only way is up and it's
you know that the sky is the limit right
as we see lots of exciting plans for you
too you think that the biggest one
learning from last year like we built
loads of great content on megalodons and
skeleton ships a new reading to explore
all the kind of updates that we had
intro'd it's paused on air we tall tales
marina two platforms to continue to grow
the game with I think one of the biggest
things we learned from last year is just
around the predictability of updates
I think getting into that kind of
predictable rhythm so where players know
when to get excited you know you know if
you want to go play another game when
can I come back to see it these it's not
just you know when they get an update
they play it it had some great content
in there and then it's like we'd be
crafting the next thing and we wouldn't
be we wouldn't be able to tell when it's
going to come next but getting into that
predictable rhythm for year 2 yeah lots
of exciting plans and looking forward to
showing what's coming next soon yeah
we're not jealous are we the jealous
type sly if a player's want to go and
play another game for a while that's
absolutely fine but they should know
they should know when to come back and
so but but for the last year honestly
that the fact is that we know we were
sporadic and tell me of what we were
doing and when and how big were the
updates and what was in them and
everything because it was all about just
grow the game and now how do it like
like literally we did an all-hands
meeting
week talking to the team about pretty
much the same stuff we're talking about
here which is like here's what we've
done here's what we've learned here's
the success we've had and now from a
player facing perspective let's get
regularity so there's a cadence and
people know when to look forward to the
next thing and so there's always a
regular stuff of things to do new
voyages new client accommodations and
rewards new cosmetics to earn and then
we'll also add in like alongside that
when it when it's ready like new tall
tales and new features and new stuff for
arena because you know we have to
balance being player kind of focused and
first and having that regular cadence
but also sustainability for the team
because for the last year or so we've
been going hard at it right and and even
before that prior to launch it was just
you know we launched the game and
normally when it's not service you have
that time to chill and relax and kind of
just bask in the glory of you know
unadulterated success but then on every
game that's always happened see if you
like less work after line something you
guys anymore yeah we did it we like we
we grew the team like we invested more
kind of into like in that in the last
year then we almost did before because
we had this success at launch and it was
like okay we're all in right and but we
we've been going at a pace that isn't
sustainable and the team has done an
amazing job but you know we have these
are the two kind of pillars of our of
our plans going forward its cadence and
regularity for players but it's also
making it so that there's flexibility in
the plans as to when something's land
along as long as stuffs always going out
to players and we've got the regularity
doesn't matter what like as much like
when's like the bigger more riskier
things land from a development
perspective like we give what we give
ourselves that time so that's our
commitment to our players and it's a
commitment to our team because we have
to do both like what makes it
unsustainable what's that what makes the
current model unsustainable are you
working it's just like you know we we
put a lot of stuff into anniversary like
but it's the biggest update we've ever
done all of the different bits that is a
completely new mode in arena a
completely new way to play in tall tales
and plus the you know the harpoon the
fishing yeah all of those features and
so like to do new things like they're
the most unpredictable because you're
iterating you're prototyping it's hard
to pick a date when it's going to land
but we wanted to create this moment in
time with anniversary to kind of to pull
it together to to kind of get everybody
took on a look
paksy needs to go oh wow that that's the
kind of you know that is co thieves 2.0
right and so and we wanted to bring
competition and short accession options
in with Reno and this narrative stuff
but but both by doing the new things and
doing tilt outs for the first time now
we have the platform to go and do mortal
Towers we know how long they take we
didn't know how long they took tonight
before alright so we're in a much better
position to plan and build more of that
stuff but when you're doing all this new
stuff bringing it all in together at the
same time to a specific date like it's
really hard to get that right and you
know one of the things that we didn't
deliver for anniversary that we plan was
pets and and ultimately we were planning
to bring in kind of in-game monetization
with the anniversary update so you know
what year after launch we haven't had
any kind of additional revenue being
generated apart from the kind of sales
and we were always open we were gonna do
it and we were going to bring pets in
but they what they didn't quite reach
the bar that we set ourselves and and we
didn't want to force them in and we
didn't want to kind of go to that team
you know what you've just gotta deliver
like like we've made it come into our
players we've got to get them in so we
so now I'm premised yeah you don't have
compromised on that kind of vision like
like with pets as well we want them to
feel like they're part of series they've
got that policy of these different
cities magic that opportunity with humor
and surprise if you've got that little
pet psychic with you you all that have
the social value on the crew like need
not just be a cosmetic it's got to have
that CFP that touch that see of these
magic and that's what we're trying to
know right yeah and so yeah and so you
know so we but the point is that we made
decision not to put those in because of
that but but it's bringing in loads of
things together at one time it's hard
and especially if they all knew and so
we don't want to do that again we don't
want to have an anniversary update in a
year's time we want to get into a more
particular regular cadence because I
think our players will enjoy that but
there will always be surprise and
delight along the way with the things
that we're doing and when stuff calms
but but it's it has to be a way that we
can run as a team and we can find the
time to not only deliver awesome stuff
for our players but we can find the time
to make sure people get training and
they can go and do presentations and
talks and you know that that all of the
stuff where you're growing humans and
and kind of like just running a
successful business and pleasing your
players but also growing your team and
being respectful of the
fact that like we're all humans and
we're working on this and we have to it
has to feel like a normal day-to-day
business and not just this relentless
gonna drive it must be so hard in the
specifics of how much feedback do we
take from everybody but like if you
listen to too much it stops being your
game but then also if you don't listen
to them at all you're gonna get in a
bubble I imagine that must be a super
tricky balance isn't because I think
we've all we we've got our own kind of
principles of like what makes ear
thieves hear thieves and it's not to say
I mean some of the ideas are like just
put knight in the game that is a day's a
perfect idea for someone's ear thieves
but like don't say some ideas about it's
just they they don't fit in see a
thieves or they they complement
compromise some of their design
principles or it would lead to exploits
it would lead to certain things being
overpowered so you know I think I think
taking feedback from their fans around
what is important right now
like the game is always evolving you
know the the way features interacting
that shared world is always changing
they're always adding kind of new
ingredients and how those ingredients
interact kind of sets the tone for the
world how aggressive players are being
how much they're working together like
what trade income is they interact with
the most what where a player's putting a
lot the group there's too much of a
grind they're not progressing fast
enough like that's where we've that's
that well it's the beauty of having a
live audience right like you got
passionate bunch of developers we all
love air game trying to grow it and
evolve it but we've got real players
that they're playing a game and
experimenting with things in different
ways and you've constantly got a look at
that you've constant got to see where
the pain points where can we make
quality of life improvements is it right
to bring fishing in there is it right to
bring things like tall tales in there
where should we invest their time to
make see if these better today and
that's always going to change and that's
why you've got to work closely with
their players
yeah and it's because you're right it's
feedback but it's also data and it's
like combining the two and you know our
intuition right it's exactly yeah and
looking at like and it's kind of like
sometimes it's trying to solve a crime
isn't it pick your way through a crime
scene they take the right like for
whatever better analogy but to kind of
flew in the right bits of evidence yeah
but like it's just a bunch of inputs
right like if some if if a bunch of air
players are being really vote for a
particular area it doesn't necessarily
mean they mean that very specific thing
it might mean that it's actually the the
result of a cause over here so you've
got to kind of build up that picture
using data using sentiment on social
media using feedback on air forums and
kind of piece together the picture of
what are what are the main issues what
con content is really gonna please their
pop players at that one point but at the
same time it's not just about like Joe
said it there when you mentioned kind of
intuition it's not just about giving
people exactly what they want because
there's that part of it but you also
wanna surprise players you want we want
to put something into the game and go I
never would have thought of that like
for example like ideas around I really
want to have a wheelbarrow in Sierre
thieves because I can port on my quest
items inside and take it back and like
like err version of that is like the
collectors chest right like really
specific example of like having a chest
in the game that you can open to pirate
world it makes perfect sense but you can
put your stuff inside and you can close
the lady and carry it around like we
always try and surprise their players
and that seems like a really simple
mechanic but you put that in their
shared world and it's a tool it's a tool
that they can use and like surprise
players with like use it to like bait
people out down to it on they open it
there's nothing inside and people pop
out the bushes and take them down like
all these ways that won't surprise their
players we always try and do that yeah
awesome
well guys unfortunately we're out of
time but again congrats on all of a
sudden like comeback you've been having
this year and between do framing and
players you've been buying the game and
playing it and good luck with the future
and also like congrats on the recent
updates
yeah and enjoy the rest of the show get
some rest if you're watching from home
this was Joe and Mike from rare and we
are gonna be back momentarily so don't
go anywhere
see you then
[Music]
[Applause]